[Musique]
ceci demande une vraie les intéristes le
27 janvier 1945 l'armée soviétique
libère à auschwitz le plus grand des
camps de concentration nazi situé sur le
territoire de la pologne occupée par les
troupes allemandes entre 1 5 et 4
millions de personnes y furent
exterminés mais certains prisonniers ont
survécu donc deux soeurs de varsovie qui
avait été envoyé dans ce camp alors
qu'elle était encore adolescente ont
leur participation à la résistance
polonaise au cas j'aurai les et est
opératrice radio soigner les malades ou
aide est à construire des barricades
elles ont été arrêtées au cours de
l'insurrection de varsovie en 1944 puis
se sont retrouvés en urss après la
guerre aujourd'hui lydia tchoukovskaïa
et xenia revas habite à moscou ils sont
90 et 91 ans et ont raconté à alerter ce
qu'elles ont enduré pendant la guerre c
maximum
lydia maxime en espace xenia lydia merci
beaucoup de nous avoir accordé du temps
aujourd'hui l'anniversaire d'une
terrible tragédie approche mais il ya
aussi quelque chose de réjouissant dans
cet anniversaire
puisqu'il s'agit de la date à laquelle
le camp d'auschwitz a été libéré en ce
moment oui vous avez vous même vécu la
réalité d'auschwitz et des camps
d'extermination nazis en général les
j'aimerais vous en parler aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'il allait dire aussi nous
pourrons peut-être aussi évoqué
l'histoire de l'occupation de la pologne
parce que vous avez tous vu de vos
propres yeux
oui s'il n'y avait pas eu d' occupation
rien de tout cela n'aurait eu lieu mais
l'occupation a eu lieu donc tout ce que
nous avons vécu a été la conséquence
directe de l'occupation fasciste
oui bien sûr c'est l'une des histoires
les plus effrayantes de la seconde
guerre mondiale quand on met le sort des
enfants qui ont duré tout ça est encore
plus horrible où étiez vous quand
l'occupation a commencé
l'occupation a commencé l'été il faisait
chaud que c'était peut-être au mois de
septembre ou au mois d'août
je ne me rappelle plus exactement d'où
nous étions avec notre mère quelque part
dans un village un petit village 0 il
était passé au loch et nous vivions au
rez de chaussée
au premier il y avait d'autres familles
qui venaient chaque année pour les
vacances c'était des habitués et haddad
n'a toujours alors que nous étions assis
tous ensemble c'était déjà l'hiver et à
une vieille les allemands sont venus ils
sont entrés dans le village et ont
chassé tout le monde du rez de chaussée
ils nous ont rassemblés au premier étage
les paires la tâche je vous dis ils ont
mis tout le monde au premier étage pour
occuper le rez-de-chaussée puis ils ont
commencé à voir et à faire la bringue
célébrer leur rentrée en pologne mais il
était tellement ivre qu'il prenait comme
cible de petits enfants et leur tirer
dessus vous relatez aussi dans votre
biographie bouleversante une histoire
selon laquelle ils ont voulu vous
abattre vous et les autres passagers
d'un tram à cause d'un allemand et où
nous étions ensemble toutes les deux
voilà ce qui nous est arrivé
on revenait de l'oin cas c'était l'été
j'avais 10 ans moi ou 11 ans à peu près
cet âge-là je ne me rappelle pas
exactement
non nous étions assises dans un tram
ces vieux trams était petit il y avait
une porte centrale
la première près du conducteur et une à
l'arrière prod beau la première était
furent deutsch c'est-à-dire vézère
aux allemands nous nous devions passer
par les deux autres porte il n'y avait
pas trop de monde 15 personnes environ
et le fait que à l'époque une jeune
organisation lutter contre le fascisme
et nous ne le savions pas être salée les
allemands imprimer des tracts sur du
papier rose et les coller sur les murs
il était écrit que pour chaque allemand
tué à la 60 personnes seraient abattus
indépendamment de l'âge et du sexe
finalement deux tués et 40 personnes se
réfugier
qu'il s'agisse d'enfants d'hommes ou de
femmes nous étions des enfants
et quand un allemand a posé le pied sur
une marche quelqu'un lui a tiré dans le
dos il est tombé mort au montana colors
ils ont immédiatement encerclé le tram
les allemands sont arrivés tout de suite
ils ont commencé à nous pousser dehors
ils nous ont expulsés du tram et nous on
me contre un mur puis ils se sont
immédiatement répartis pour former une
chaîne leur fusil braqué sur nous on
était quinze vingt ans au maximum
mais il avait besoin de 60 personnes
donc ils ont organisé une rafle ils
encerclent et les gens les attraper dans
les rues dans leurs maisons partout où
ils pouvaient tout simplement pour avoir
60 personnes et ces noms et des femmes
des enfants peu importe il devait nous
fusiller mais comme je dis dieu veille
toujours sur nous et lydia se tenait à
gauche et moi on m'a poussée à droite
j'étais debout à côté d'un garçon il me
paraissait adultes mais je crois que
c'était un garçon il m'a dit en
chuchotant fuyons quand il s'est mis à
courir il n'a pas pu l'attraper car on
avait les mains en l'air hagard il faut
pourtant dans le jeu mais il a couru je
les ai vus courir et je me suis mise à
courir aussi à béjaia vais-je langage il
ya pas méchant ce qui est arrivé à lydia
je n'en sais rien mais je sais que ça a
été plus facile pour elle fait étape à
blaye charles plutôt bien parce que je
me suis mise à courir et ils ont ouvert
le feu il y avait bien sûr des gens qui
tombent et j'ai réussi à tourner à
gauche
il y avait une petite rue je l' ai
aperçu et je me suis faufilé j'étais
petit mince et agile et j'ai réussi à
m'échapper une femme marcher le long de
la rue avec un enfant elle a vu le
désarroi
apparemment ça se voyait sur mon visage
que j'étais un folie c'était finalement
si je comprends bien une allemande oui
mais je ne savais pas qu'elle était
allemande elle marchait avec sa fille en
lui tenant la main elle m'a vu elle
aussi été affolés et elle m'a attrapé
par la main elle a tout compris et elle
est allé dans la direction opposée vers
les allemands il y avait un agent de la
gestapo à l'entrée et elle lui a dit ban
ki moon nous a laissé passer je dis
toujours qu'il ya différentes sortes
d'allemands cette femme pleurer en
regardant par la fenêtre
ils ont attrapé 60 personnes et les ont
fusillé immédiatement après cela des
voitures sont arrivées des voitures
noires et ils ont rapidement emporté
tous les cadavres
ensuite une autre voiture est arrivée à
nettoyer le sang c'est à dire qu'en
l'espace d'une demi-heure tout était
déjà propre cela se passait très
rapidement et c'est souvent arrivé
c'était quelqu'un c'est bon nous dit
vous avez été séparés alors oui vous
êtes parti avec cette allemande et vous
êtes resté avec votre mère comment vous
êtes vous retrouvée je suis rentré chez
moi
elle a dit maman maman avait peur même
deux je lui ai dit roues et xenia nous
avons couru dans des directions
différentes
elle connaissait la situation est bien
sûr toujours peur de nous laisser sortir
seul parce que ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'ils se livrer à de telles
actions
on est les seuls à l'école on était
seuls partout ce n'était pas la première
fois
l'allemande m'a laissé partir mais une
fois que toute la rue avait été nettoyée
elle m'a rappelé panier dehors et j'ai
marché jusqu'à chez moi
nous vivions dans le centre de varsovie
et moi je suis rentré à la maison tout
de suite bien sûr j'étais dans un état
terrible parce que la première fois
qu'on a vu une exécution c'est quand les
allemands sont entrés dans le village
pat entame ensuite il y a eu ces rafles
il faisait des rafts tous les jours
plusieurs fois par jour pagnol
d'accord donc au début de l'occupation
vous aviez respectivement 10 et 11 ans
et bien si on compte oui ça doit être ça
oui et nous étions très jeunes mais
malheureusement à la fin les nazis vous
sont arrêtés ainsi que votre mère pouvez
vous nous raconter cela je vais vous
raconter cela maintenant le fait est que
pendant le soulèvement ils ont jeté
trois fois des trades nature où les gens
commençaient à ne pas mourir à cause des
balles mais à cause des maladies
il n'y avait pas d'eau il n'y avait rien
à manger quand on me demandait ce que je
mangeais alors je répondais aucune idée
je ne mangeais rit encore nous avons
mangé notre chat oui il faut le dire
nous avons mangé notre chat on avait
extrêmement fins ils ont jeté des tracts
trois fois les gens sortis il était
écrit sur ces tracts rendez vous sinon
tout votre varsovie sera réduite en
cendres ceux qui se rendront nous
garantirons la vie et une existence
normale
il y a eu une heure de calme ni les
allemands ni les polonais ne tirait les
gens sortent et il tenait des foulards
on voyait les gens marcher dans les
ruines leurs fleurs à la main cette
chaîne
cette situation s'est répétée deux fois
en deux mois
à la fin du troisième mois fin septembre
ils ont ajouté des tracts pour la
dernière fois où ils ont écrit le
prendrez vous sinon nous vous massacres
ont tous il ma mère a dit on restera ici
omura ici on n'ira nulle part
nous n'avons nulle part où aligner coup
d'essai est allaité saint malo les
avions sont arrivés les avions volaient
avec un bourdonnement vous savez un
bruit très sourd donc cela signifié
qu'il il volait vers le centre nous
vivions dans le centre il y avait le
palais royal il y avait tout c'était le
centre ville et soudain d'autres avions
sont apparus ces derniers étaient légers
piech beau un violent combat aérien a eu
lieu un peu plus tard les allemands sont
entrés ils sont entrés ils ont dit c'est
avec greg
ils ont fait sortir tout le monde nous
n'avions rien parce que tout ce que nous
avions avaient brûlé tout avait été
rasée et et nous sommes sortis on ne
portant que des petites robes des
sandales nous sommes sortis et quand
nous sommes sortis l'un d'eux a commencé
à incendie pour que personne ne reste là
on nous a fait rejoindre la colonne la
colonne était déjà en marche à travers
toutes ces ruines à travers tout ça nous
marchons sans eau sans nourriture tous y
compris les malades les infirmes les
affamés et deux côtés il y avait des
allemands avec des chiens et ceux qui
tombaient c'était fini pour eux oui si
quelqu'un tombe et on loue à fusiller
tout de suite si quelqu'un s'arrêter on
le fusiller on nous emmener au camp
c'était donc au moment où on vous
emmener au camp oui oui le premier camp
pruskow ou approche quasi exactement le
premier quand c'était pruskow près de
varsovie à côté de varsovie la salle a
aussi été énorme une énorme salle
quand nous sommes arrivés il faisait
déjà nuit il faisait presque nuit là il
y avait 300 personnes je dirais il
entasse est tout le monde de tous
varsovie c'est tout varsovie qui
marchait dans cette colonne et là aussi
se tenait un allemand il était
impossible de sortir de faire quoi que
ce soit il y avait les toilettes si
quelqu'un devait en avoir besoin
ils n'apportaient pas d'eau rien ils
n'apportaient rien du tout il y avait
des mères avec des nourrissons
à ce moment là vous étiez encore avec
votre mère c'est ça oui maman était avec
une wii avec maman maman était avec nous
elle était très inquiète parce que on
nous porte et nous ne pouvions pas
marché moi au moins j'avais des bâtons
et lydia est aussi faible
elle était malade mais quand les
allemands s'approcher de nous on nous
faisait nous mettre au sol pour qu'on ne
nous fusil pas pour qu'ils croient que
vous étiez en bonne santé
oui tout ça à cause de la faim combien
de temps nous avons passé à cusco quand
on nous pose la question on ne sait pas
quoi répondre c'est comme si nous avions
perdu
la notion du temps j'imagine oui il ya
un moment les allemands se sont mis aux
portes et ont commencé à faire le tri il
était là à observer ils n'avaient pas de
document rien du tout il était là debout
ils nous regardent et le physique à
gauche c'était les enfants les malades
les infirmes les vieillards les femmes
avec des nourrissons
donc ceux qui ne pouvaient pas
travailler ce qui ne pouvait pas
travailler tous à gauche à droite
maman ils ont tout simplement jeter loin
de nous maman n'a eu le temps que de
pousser un cri
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit elle à crier les
filles tenait vous toute la vie par la
main ne vous séparez jamais voilà
c'était les dernières paroles de notre
mère et on nous a tous mis dans des
wagons à bestiaux sans toit sans rien
ils ne savions pas où nous en sommes à
la codah les sommes qu'ils savaient
comme il y avait des hommes aussi
il soulevait des planches et alors que
le train roulait comme ça il sautait sur
la voie je ne sais pas s'il s'en sont
tirés ou non parce qu'il savait où nous
emmener parce qu'il y avait l'ordre
d'hitler de détruire varsovie ceux qui
s'étaient rendus devait être fusillé ce
qui était encore en vie
les malades tous les survivants devaient
être éliminés par quels moyens on n'en
savait rien vous comprenez on nous
emmener en fait pour nous éliminer
parce que là vraiment il y avait des
vieillards des malades des enfants
surtout des enfants des enfants
on vous a emmené à auschwitz après c'est
ça oui combien de temps avez vous passé
auschwitz octobre novembre décembre
nous y avons passé trois mois en
décembre on nous a envoyés en décembre
vous envoyer ailleurs on ne prenait du
sang j'ai un peu étudié la question de
ces trois mois et si j'ai bien compris
vous aviez un groupe sanguin très rare
ne savions pas vous le saviez pas mais
vous l'avez appris là bas oui mais on
s'en souviendra toute notre vie
d'accord on vous emmener donc souvent
pour pas souvent ce n'était pas souvent
animal la chasse la base il ne pouvait
pas faire cela souvent parce que nous
n'avions pas suffisamment de force one
et les ont emmenés en groupe
un petit groupe il y avait une femme
chef de bloc qui venait très près et
nous aligner une allemande venez on nous
emmener dans un autre baraquements qui
s'appelait rivère la croix rouge là il y
avait un mur avec des trous comme ça
dans les trous comme ça et vous nous
voyez donc pas qu'ils ont donné du sang
vous veniez non on mettait le bras dans
le trou on ne savait pas combien de sang
et prony et après elles ne regardaient
il n'omettait comme ça et ce avec
quelqu'un qui tombe et il ya eu des cas
où les gens se sentaient mal non
personne ne tombe et il y avait une
couche est là mais ce qu' il y avait
aussi des enfants plus petits déj
différents et ceux ci on nous aligner de
nouveau nous retournions à la baraque
les enfants qui restent et perdez
connaissance
beaucoup d'entre eux ne revenait plus à
la baraque voilà c'est à chénier vous
savez si nous avions perdu connaissance
nous serions pas retourner à la baraque
et si on y retournait pas cela voulait
dire qu'on allait être incinérés ou
qu'on allait faire l'objet d'expériences
derrière auschwitz il y avait un
bâtiment un grand bâtiment où on faisait
des expériences nous n'en savions rien à
l'époque c'est plus tard que nous
l'avons après ne connaissions que notre
baraque
alors voilà on est en décembre aux
sommes à peine vêtues les puces nous
dévore ses wagons à bestiaux sont à
nouveau arriver mais il avait des toits
cette fois les mêmes que quand nous
étions en demie à auschwitz ils nous ont
fait monter dans ce wagon
je ne sais pas comment étaient les
autres wagons mais je me souviens d'une
autre et voilà comment c'était c'était
l'hiver on portaient des robes samba et
on avait des chaussures en bois ils nous
ont permis de nous envelopper dans ces
couvertures plein de
trou c'était pas vraiment des
couvertures plutôt des draps nous sommes
sortis et ils nous ont juste poussé dans
ses wagons il nous pousse est
littéralement dedans il y avait de tels
fente dans les murs de ces wagons que
lorsque le train était en marche
il y avait de très forts courants nous
étions encore en route et on a alors
compris que ce n'était plus du polonais
les gens parler allemand
c'est à dire qu'on se trouvaient en
territoire allemand on pouvait entendre
tout ce qu'il disait tout un remue
ménage il arrivait que le train s'arrête
et on attendait dans notre wagon des
gens ont commencé à mourir parce qu'il y
avait aussi des blessés il était exténué
il y avait des mères avec des
nourrissons
vous savez quand quelqu'un mourait les
adultes empiler les cadavres pour
obstruer les fentes pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de courants d'air nous étions en
chemin depuis déjà longtemps est enfin
prêt mais cela nous sommes arrivés stay
on a dû attendre encore un peu bachelet
ils ont ouvert la porte du matin à la
sape les hommes en uniforme rayé sont
monté dans le wagon
vous avez tous des numéros je crois
alors ils sont montés ils ont d'abord
sorti les morts et il les en compte et
ils ont sorti est compté ils ont fait
sortir ce qui pouvait marcher deux très
rapidement pas tant ensuite il faut
porter ce qui ne pouvait pas marcher
pas seulement nous il y en avait
d'autres qui étaient incapables de
marcher elle s'est avéré que c'était des
prisonniers du camp de concentration
neuengamme c'était des prisonniers c'est
le camp de hambourg où vous avez été
amené
c'est ça nous étions dans un camp pour
femmes
à ce moment là vous étiez déjà très
malade vous étiez incapable de vous
déplacer
selon vous pourquoi vous ont-ils envoyé
à l'infirmerie au lieu de vous tuer vous
étiez très malade
nous étions faible très faible mais nous
pouvions marché quand même oui faible
lydia été capable de marcher elle
n'avait pas mal aux jambes
moi si je passe le balai par exemple
vous faisait tout votre possible pour
leur faire croire que vous étiez encore
en bonne santé
non en fait nous pouvions marché mais
nous n'avons pas pu descendre du wagon
puis si quelqu'un ne pouvait pas marcher
c'était fini on n'a pas pu descendre
c'est pour ça qu'il nous porte et il
fallait descendre et mes jambes refusé
de bouger
maintenant je peux marcher mais à ce
moment là ils nous ont prises dans leurs
bras et portait des voitures noires nous
attendait déjà ils nous ont poussé
dedans et nous ont emmenés c'était près
de hambourg
j'ai appris plus tard qu'il y avait
plein de camps comme ça dans les
alentours naguère abonné des camps pour
femmes
il y avait des femmes de différentes
nationalités d'âge et même des
allemandes
les anglaises aussi et beaucoup de
russes il y avait des polonaises
également en infirmier allemands
venaient l'été de la gestapo pour
observer l'état de chacune et on se
parle est humble et j'allais vous
comprenez il y en avait qui ne se levait
même pas ils ont été emportés alors des
polonais sont arrivés et ont appris
qu'il y avait là des participants à
l'insurrection de varsovie
l'une d'elle s'appelait sonia une jeune
fille très bien elle était prisonnière
aussi alors elle était prisonnière de ce
camp elle venait prendre soin de ceux
qui en avaient besoin
les allemands ne l'aurais pas fait il
fallait vider les basses en etc bref
soigner les malades
vous aviez la chance de leur parler par
exemple sur elles nous ont sauvés oui
nous ont sauvés elle nous répétait sans
cesse manger bien vous devez survivre
pour raconter tout raconter toutes ces
horreurs et c'est ce que nous avons fait
en secret ils ont fait beaucoup de
choses pour nous ils nous ont sauvés
elle nous disait tout doucement quand le
docteur arrivée levé vous
prenez quelque chose un ballet où
n'importe quoi ne restez pas couché et
on se levait même si on ne se sentait
pas bien où on avait mal peu importe on
travaille un jour ces polonais sont
entrés en courant et ont crié libre
libre libre vous savez nous étions
indifférente libre ou non à un moment
donné on voulait plus vivre à cet âge là
à 13 ans il n'avions tout simplement
plus la volonté de vivre je vois
l'horreur absolue
mais après la seconde guerre mondiale
votre vie n'a pas été facile non plus
surtout au début après la libération
vous vous êtes retrouvé en union
soviétique bien sûr c'était pas facile
on a vraiment connu la faim à varsovie
vous étiez livré à vous-même alors c'est
les militaires russes qu'ils ne
recevaient je vais raconter ça pour toi
lydia après je m'en souviens plus parce
qu'il faut tout raconté dans l'ordre il
se trouve que quand les anglais nous ont
libérés ils nous ont proposé d'aller en
angleterre
nous leur avons répondu non nous allons
chercher notre mère polonaise s'occuper
de nous elle aussi prenez la direction
de la pologne
vous savez les gens se divisait en
groupe il y avait des russes des
allemandes elles ont décidé de s'occuper
de nous avec beaucoup de difficultés je
ne sais même pas comment on a fait ça
mais nous sommes parvenus à nous rendre
à varsovie
elle n'était pas de varsovie ils nous
ont envoyé à varsovie et on a cherché
notre rue on l'a trouvé il n'y avait
rien on a écrit sur un mur
maman nous lydia et xenia que nous
sommes ici nous pensions que maman
reviendrai on ne l'a pas trouvé et on
voulait manger
nous avons commencé à chercher quelque
chose à manger ont marché
il y avait déjà un groupe d'enfants un
groupe s'est rassemblé il était composée
d'enfants de la rue nous étions aussi
des enfants de la rue chez rapport nous
nous sommes réunis pour trouver quelque
chose à manger
donc on sentait une odeur qui venait
voilà ici il y avait quelque chose à
manger
on a vu des soldats qui étaient assis et
qui mangeaient dans leur gamelle on
voulait aussi
oui on en veut nous ont donné du pain
ils nous ont donné un peu de sucre bref
nous y sommes allés plusieurs fois
chaque fois qu'on était là il nous
donnait à manger
non apparemment ils nous attendaient et
bien nous avons compris que c'était une
langue slave attend beaucoup de mots
étaient similaires
il y avait ceux qui les biélorusses
étaient là peut-être qu'il comprenait
déjà nous disait quelque chose et on a
commencé à les comprendre aussi leur
chef est venu un supérieur hiérarchique
cette ville on va il a dit qu'ils
allaient nous réunir qu'il fallait nous
soigner qu'on était tous malades en
lambeaux zoua famille chute ou qu'il
fallait nous éduquer il a dit qu'il
fallait d'abord nous soigner et ensuite
éduqué je dis quelque chose ne va pas
ici ce n'est pas la même langue nous ont
emmenés et il ne nous faisait pas tous
descendre en même temps mais petit à
petit il en faisait descendre dans une
ville et ils nous ont libérés dans une
autre ville alors c'était déjà en union
soviétique
autrement dit vous avez été envoyés dans
différentes villes vous êtes quand même
rester ensemble parce que oui c'était en
union soviétique à brest oui dans des
différentes villes oui nous étions deux
à descendre à abobo aujourd'hui c'est en
biélorussie en biélorussie à brest on ne
faisait que regarder par la fenêtre ça
maintenant parce qu'elles se ressemblent
à le biélorusse c'est le polonais cela
nous a sauvés du retard je pense que
c'est parce que lorsque la bbc nous a
demandés en interview on a dit aux
journalistes qu'il y avait deux femmes
de varsovie non pas d'un show on lui a
dit vas leur parler il a tout de suite
compris qu'on était de varsovie des
camps de concentration il m'a demandé
comment vous avez été accueillis
comment cela s'est passé
car il voulait quelque chose de négatif
à l'époque staline était encore en vie
et je lui réponds nous étions ravis de
nous trouver en union soviétique en nous
soigner c'était vous voyez que la guerre
était quelque chose de terrible à
bovrisse on marchait on cherchait
quelque chose à manger
on est arrivés dans un village il y
avait des tuyaux des mitrailleuses
il y avait un combat et donc je dis que
nous sommes heureuses d'avoir été emmené
on a des malades quand on a trouvé une
église
nous sommes entrés dans l'église qui
avaient des prêtres on croyait en dieu
nous avez appris le catéchisme
la pologne était catholique le
biélorusse et le polonais se ressemblent
beaucoup à die
oui votre église était catholique en
union soviétique il y avait plus
d'églises orthodoxes
oui c'était une église orthodoxe et on a
trouvé une église un pop est sorti il
avait une barde
il nous a paru vieux un prêtre orthodoxe
oui peut-être qu'il était jeune mais il
avait une barbe et il a tout de suite
tout compris il a compris et il nous a
emmenés dans une pièce il nous a dit
asseyez vous racontez moi tout en détail
nous avons tout raconter comme cela
s'était passé pour nous l'essentiel
il a posé beaucoup de questions puis il
a dit ne racontais jamais où vous étiez
ce que vous avez vécu il ya une guerre
et c'est tout j'ai dit pourquoi il a
répondu vous comprendrez plus tard
pourquoi il nous a sauvé voilà en
général ce qui a été notre vie il reste
de moins en moins de gens qui se
souviennent de la guerre qui peuvent la
raconter merci beaucoup pour cela mais
c'est un étang de plus en plus de gens
veulent pour ainsi dire réécrire
l'histoire de la seconde guerre mondiale
malheureusement que pensez vous de ces
voix qui dit gros seins en europe même
en pologne s'élèvent de plus en plus
souvent pour blâmer l'urss d'avoir
déclenché la guerre et impute les
atrocités de cette guerre à ceux qui ont
libéré l'europe
que pouvez vous dire à propos des gens
qui parlent ainsi à mon avis ceux qui
pensent à réécrire cette histoire
doivent aller fouiller dans les archives
on va trouver des documents et tout lire
tout est là dans les archives il faut
apprendre cette histoire et puis écouter
ceux qui ont vécu cette guerre il ya
toujours des gens en pologne qui ont
participé à la seconde guerre mondiale
et à la grande guerre patriotique
c'est pour ça qu'ils connaissent
l'histoire j'estime que c'est
inacceptable
réécrit l'histoire est tout à fait
on ne peut pas tolérer ça ils n'ont pas
le droit de la réécrire j'estime qu'il
faut fouiller dans toutes les archives
et lire les documents cartes outillés et
tout dépend de nous des anciens qui ont
fait que cette guerre et des maximums
lydia maximum
xénia c'est lydia merci à vous d'exister
merci à vous de nous avoir raconté
l'histoire de votre vie que dieu vous
accorde encore de nombreuses années
vous soyez heureuse et bien sûr que vous
profitiez encore de votre vie les années
passent mais le temps passe
[Musique]